The army thought the experiment was a
failure
but their drug didn't work but it just
took a little time to turn you into
Deathstroke
where's my boy where's joseph will you
join hive
or will my man slit little joseph's
throat here and now
the answer is no
you're a mercenary
and the people that you love have paid a
terrible price
you see i have a secret
i'm a knight like the ones in our
favorite book
roaming a dangerous world and i don't
want those dragons to hurt you
ever again
so what are we going to do about it we
you're not going after him alone this time
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new batman deathstroke
video that's right they made a
deathstroke movie if you can believe it
so i'll explain what's going on with
this what's going on with the larger
reboot
of the dc animated movies since justice
league apocalypse war
and what's going on with deathstroke in
the live-action dceu movies after
justice league
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the easter eggs
we'll do an amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know what you want them to do
with deathstroke in the new
dc movies the basic premise of the movie
is that this retells a version of his
origin story but it is different from
the canonical
comic book version of his origin story
that you've seen in a lot of the other
adaptations
they did a version of deathstroke on
titan season 2 recently as part of the
nightwing origin story
they were doing the judas contract
storyline during that season so they
told his backstory as part of the judas
contract
classic teen titans story but this
version of the movie
changes some of the aspects about his
family members and where they come from
so for instance rose wilson's backstory
is ravager is a little bit different
jericho's backstory is a little bit
different and as you can tell it's
michael chiklis playing
deathstroke so obviously we have another
version of deathstroke so i will talk
about how i thought he did compared to
the other versions of deathstroke like
manu bennett or joe manginello's
deathstroke
but the movie is basically deathstroke
versus hive with a couple other villains
they introduce but it all winds up being
a twist upon a twist upon a twist
it's all about being double-crossed how
do you portray deathstroke is an
anti-hero if he does such terrible
terrible things
most of the other dc series that have
used the character have portrayed him as
more of a villain i think they've slowly
tried to humanize them
especially on the flash and arrow where
they use the character a ton of times
the way they accomplish that in this
movie is by putting him against villains
through
hive that have no moral code no sense of
honor and that's his whole thing is that
he does do terrible
things but he does have a code of honor
that he operates by he's supposed to be
true neutral
a true mercenary as happens in the
comics usually what winds up getting him
though is his past
catches up to him and bites him in the
ass sometimes literally
the movie focuses heavily on the
consequences of his actions and how it
destroys his family and his broken
relationships with his wife with his two
children
the biggest change they make from the
comics though is that there's no grant
wilson as part of this storyline
a lot of you may have seen a version of
this earlier this year when they
released it on cwc
in a bunch of smaller chunks so what
they're doing now is they're just
combining it all into a blu-ray and home
video that they're releasing next week
so if it seems weird or you're having
deja vu like wait a minute didn't i
already watch this
you probably did it's just that they're
releasing it in a slightly different way
i'm not as big a fan of the animation in
this as i am of some of the other dc
properties usually dc animated movies
are really solid but it just depends on
the team inside dc that's animating the
project
one of the other really weird things
about this though is that they end on a
big cliffhanger and i do not think that
there's going to be a sequel to this i
think they build it like it was going to
be a series and they were going to do a
season two to follow up on deathstroke
getting
pushed off the cliff by jericho here but
there's been no talk of them doing the
second part of this storyline since this
came out earlier this year so i have no
idea
this is kind of what it's like to be an
anime fan you see a really cool season
one but then there's no promise of a
season two in sight it just completely
vanishes into the night
just in terms of recent dc animated
properties i say justice league
apocalypse war is probably the most
solid thing that they've done so far
so this is also part of the idea that dc
is rebooting their animated continuity
if you didn't see apocalypse war is one
of their better movies that they've done
the last couple of years
at the end of that movie because they
basically completely derp that timeline
the flash pulls another flashpoint and
there's a big teaser
for dc rebirth movies like they're
trying to launch another animated
franchise through the dc rebirth title
everything would change and some of
those changes may be sh*te
but the movies that they're talking
about rebooting in terms of the line of
continuity is just the justice league
mainstream animated films the one that
started with justice league flashpoint
then justice league war where darkseid
shows up on planet earth in the justice
league forms for the first time
then more recently they did the death of
superman then the reign of the superman
and now justice league dark apocalypse
war so it's just those movies with those
voice over actors
they'll still continue to be a ton of dc
movies every year
but they're just using the opportunity
to bring in new creative bring in new
voice over actors
so for instance the brand new superman
movie superman man of tomorrow that
they're going to be
releasing next week as part of dc fandom
has a completely different voice over
cast and the animation style looks
vastly vastly different from the
animation style of these justice league
animated films
you're all getting excited about robert
pattinson and matt reeves new batman
movie that's based on the long halloween
story line
will dc announce that they're actually
doing batman the long halloween is an
animated movie
sometime next year too there's no
trailer for that yet so we haven't seen
any animation
but it'll also be another example of
them just trying different things new
teams new animation styles so it'll be
fun to see what that actually looks like
the last we've seen deathstroke in the
live action movies right now
is actually the justice league
theatrical cut joe manginello was
teasing that the justice league snyder
cut is going to have a completely
different ending in post credit scene
so i'm guessing that he has a little bit
more dialogue he barely even speaks at
all during the theatrical cut
but most of that footage was actually
shot by joss whedon so
none of that stuff that you saw in the
theatrical cut with deathstroke and lex
luthor
is going to be in the snyder cut without
having seen the full snyder cut yet all
i really know about the alternate
versions of deathstroke during that
movie is that they have a similar scene
where he breaks lex luthor out at the
end of the movie
they have a brief conversation about
setting up their own team like the
legion of doom
and that's about it but it's a very
different type of conversation that goes
down in a very different way from the
theatrical cut
originally when they cast joe
manginello's death stroke it was
actually more for
the batman movie when ben affleck was
still going to be directing and writing
that movie and starring in it
that was going to be batman vs
deathstroke in an arkham style movie
with batman fighting his way down level
by level in arkham
but ben affleck the way he explains it
left the project just because
he couldn't find a way to crack the
story and he was just so fatigued with
playing the batman character that he
wanted to pass it on to someone else
that someone else wound up being matt
reeves who then cast robert pattinson
they'll be previewing that movie at dc
fandom this weekend so we'll see a lot
more of that for the rest of the year
then after he was going to appear in the
ben affleck version of the batman movie
he would have gone on to a deathstroke
solo movie in the dc eu
we don't know a lot about that movie
other than he would have just been an
anti-hero like the mandalorian so i
think that's a good comparison to make
because they're both lived by strict
moral codes
they walk around in some crazy armor and
even though they're not evil themselves
they do have to do a lot of terrible
stuff
in the line of duty post all your
deathstroke baby yoda memes i feel like
they could have done a really awesome
version of that but the mandalorian got
there first with baby yoda in the mando
joe manginello said he would still love
to do a deathstroke movie even though it
seems like it's going to be sitting on a
shelf for a while they have no plans to
do it anytime soon
it's always possible that they bring
that character back through the suicide
squad franchise if the new james gunn
suicide squad movie is as successful as
it seems like it's going to be
just comparing michael chiklis's version
of deathstroke and his performance to
the other versions we've seen so far
i feel like he does a really solid job
he's a great actor in all the live
action stuff that he does
i feel like manu bennett is the most
well developed version of deathstroke so
i am partial to his version
i do feel like joe manginello's dceu
movie version of deathstroke could have
become the most superior version
had he gotten his do in the dc movies
but as it stands none of those movies
wound up happening so you really only
have him for a couple minutes so you
can't really say that that's completely
superior to what they did with arrow and
minou bennett's version of the character
even though
with a movie budget you could just make
it look so much better
but like i said dc fandom is happening
next week there's going to be a bunch of
dc movie trailers previews and footage
and they'll also be a bunch of video
game stuff too
for the people that are looking forward
to big batman arkham game announcements
and suicide squad game announcements
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them
and leave all your requests in the
comments below everyone click here for
my new batman 2021
preview video for dc fandom and all the
trailers that are coming up in the
panels
and click here for that brand new wonder
woman 1984 trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!